[Music]
so actually show of hands how many
people have heard of cattle okay great
how many have actually participated in a
competition or done something on cattle
okay fewer hands okay so Kaggle is the
world's largest data science community
we are nearly 2 million as you might
have caught wind of in the keynote
yesterday we span the globe so we have
people coming from all regions across
the globe there the community consists
of people from a variety of backgrounds
not just data science practitioners but
hobbyists researchers academics and even
you know software engineers and people
from all backgrounds so why are people
coming to cattle why are there 2 million
users predominantly we hear it's for
learning sharing and practicing data
science and they do that by engaging
with three products on our platform
the first being our competitions so this
is what cattle has traditionally been
most well known for this is where
companies and organizations host machine
learning problems second is our kernels
environment so this is our cloud-based
data science workbench people
collaborate and create code and
notebooks using their data sets and that
brings me to our third product which is
data sets so this is our open data
platform currently we're hosting about
nearly nine thousand public data sets
that people have uploaded to share and
use within their data science projects
so today of course because I'm with the
competitions team I am going to focus on
competitions and so you know what what
is the Kaggle competition so Kaggle
hosts a supervised machine learning
Editions and at any given time you can
visit our competitions page to see what
is live this is actually a snapshot from
several months ago but I think it gives
a nice glimpse at the type of variety
and the types of competitions that we
host from you know image classification
to forecasting and then this over here
on the right is a snapshot of a
competition that we had run with porto
seguro which is a brazilian insurance
company insurance companies commonly run
their use cases in this type of an
environment and so they were looking to
predict if a driver would file a claim
in the next year and so I'll use Porto
as kind of an example of what a
competition is and how its structured so
using that as an example competitions
the symp the set up is quite simple for
a supervised machine learning
competition we work with the hosts to
who provides a large label data set with
a target variable to predict we work
with their data science team to cleanse
and prepare the data set for the
platform and then we split it into a
training set and a test set so the
training set is what we provide to
competitors with the labels or ground
truth and that's what they train their
algorithms on to generate predictions
against a test set and that test set is
what we use to evaluate and assess the
accuracy of the algorithms that are
being submitted and so using portal as
an example if I grossly oversimplify the
data set perhaps they provided training
data including metadata on drivers age
and income he identified an anonymized
of course and and then of course the
ground truth labels of whether or not
the claim was filed
so our competitors join the competition
they download the data they build their
algorithms and
submit predictions against the test set
where the target variables answers have
been withheld we score the accuracy of
those predictions based on an evaluation
metric and then rank those competitors
on a live leaderboard and so the
leaderboard ultimately is what results
in who receives prize money sponsored by
the host of the competition and it's
this competitive dynamic that really
kind of fuels people's sort of eagerness
to kind of achieve and outpace one
another throughout the duration of the
competition and it's it's ultimately
something that we witness time and again
through looking at the score progression
over time for any given competition so
for Porto seguro we saw that over time
the score the highest leaderboard score
converged on this sort of you know
asymptote or what we consider to be kind
of the maximum of what is achievable on
that that data set in that problem so
now that I've talked a little bit about
how the competitions are set up and
structured I want to kind of bring it to
life a little bit and talk about some of
the common use cases that we witness
customers running on cattle and so I'll
talk about four different use cases and
then how the businesses are gaining
value through running a capital
competition so the first is sales
forecasting so corporación Favorita is a
leading ecuadorian grocer they were
looking to better predict and forecast
sales of items in their stores so this
is you know classic forecasting problem
as you might imagine retailers need to
get this right it affects inventory it
affects staffing and
especially when you're dealing with
perishable items where the cost of you
know shelf life is even you know more
important so Favorita provided series of
you know very rich data sets that
included things like store and item
metadata promotional activities holidays
and events in Ecuador even oil prices
and then they threw it at the community
and said you know what can you do to
predict unit sales and of course at the
end of the competition they were able to
receive the winning algorithms but one
thing that we actually find even perhaps
even more valuable than the winning
algorithms is actually the activity that
happens on our forums and so for every
competition there is a discussion and a
forum where people are able to share
ideas the approaches that they're taking
methods techniques and at the end of a
competition of course is what their
solutions and so for this type of a
competition where it's you know a
feature-rich tabular data set you saw
people doing some creative and clever
feature engineering but one revelation
that came about at the end of the
competition was discovery of the use of
wavenet for this type of a problem so
wavenet was you know conceived by deep
mind traditionally was used for you know
taking raw audio waveforms and then
generating speech but competitors found
that applying that type of you know
convolutional neural network the wavenet
was actually a great predictor of time
series data and so they applied it on
this problem and many of the leading
teams were able to make advancements in
this regard so
I'm using this as an example to
illustrate how people often share
breakthrough findings new packages novel
approaches through Kaggle and I would
even argue that sometimes you can even
track sort of the per elevation of
different types of these new concepts
through their frequency and appearance
within catalyst forums so that's our
first example secondly recommender
system so recommender systems very
commonly approached in machine learning
for Airbnb they were looking to predict
where a user would make their a new user
would make their first booking and so
the reason actually while I'm using this
example is not necessarily it wasn't
necessarily for air and be about the
solutions but really about the
approaches and the people who were
attacking their problem and that was
because they came to us running a
recruiting competition and so what we
find is that people in our community as
well as customers you know whether it's
through competitions or jobs bored or
just forum chatter are really looking to
raise their profile within the data
science community and so we have
countless stories of people finding
their next job through sharing you know
progress that they've made on Kaggle or
using their data science projects as
examples in interviews and so that's the
interview example is really about a
recruiting motivation thirdly I thought
I'd touch on another common common and
rising sort of rapidly rising use case
in machine learning which is natural
language processing so of course with
the advent of things like Google home
and assistant we're seeing a lot of
natural language processing interest on
our on our platform so Google's own
jigsaw team
was hosting a competition to help
identify and classify toxic comments and
so into actually six different
subclasses things like threats hate
obscenities that sort of thing
and their mission was to really identify
and can almost get ahead of negative
behaviors in order to promote better
online conversations a really nice noble
mission and the the jigsaw team was
actually very interested in the
different approaches that people were
taking on this sort of newer area of
study and you know the things that you
might expect out of an LP like you know
playing around with embeddings or
language normalization pre-processing
techniques
neural networks of course and just you
know throwing as much as they can at a
problem and that's actually something
that we commonly see in tackle
competitions is call it kind of the
kitchen sink method right which is all
the different techniques that you can
throw at a problem you know what sticks
what what works best what advances the
problem more and as kind of the the
title of my session suggests when you
have the this largest audience of
community members attacking a problem
with these brute-force techniques you're
bound to find something that works and
that's kind of how problems like this
advance and so one thing that we see is
evidence of that through our kernels so
for every competition there are there's
a discussion or a forum but there's also
a series of kernels that people have
shared so that's code and notebooks with
oftentimes you know baseline models and
in this particular competition there was
actually quite quite a lot of kernels
shared and
the winning algorithms tended to be some
blend of the best techniques that
surfaced to the top just an interesting
anecdote it was all about this
competition is we did some sort of post
competition analysis and discover that
any algorithm that performed quite well
on one subtype of one of those
subclasses of toxicity actually
performed quite well across all of the
subtypes so there wasn't necessarily a
specialist algorithm there were they
performed well across all subclasses
which was quite interesting so the last
area that is of course quite hot in
machine learning is image classification
computer vision to to date our highest
prize pool competition it was hosted by
the department homeland security TSA and
so if you flew here or if you've ever
flown you probably run into these
scanners and so what the TSA is trying
to do is of course detect objects that
are caused up cause for threat and then
and then you know cause for secondary
screening but of course when people are
alarmed for non threat objects so
falsely alarmed that waste people's time
it causes stress sometimes people miss
flights and so the TSA is trying to sort
of curb that those kind of false
positives
while at the same time not risking
passenger safety by missing real threats
right and so they provided a really nice
test dataset of you know volunteers
scans to mimic threat objects and then
had people identify whether or not there
was an object in each of the zones of of
a person's body and the the images that
they used were actually quite complex
and large there were two different
formats there was a 3d format and then
there
was also kind of a 2d cross-sectional
format and rather than try to explain to
you the winning algorithms and the
techniques that were used which of
course you can go to our our forums and
find out more about I thought I would
use this as an opportunity to share kind
of the walks of life and the diversity
in the walks of life that people who win
or participate in these competitions
come from so of course you're gonna have
your PhDs or advanced degree
participants who have specialized in
medical imaging have many years of
working with computer vision but you
know interesting anecdote within our ten
winners one of them was actually a UC
Berkeley freshman another was someone
who had was a data science practitioner
but actually never touched computer
vision and just wanted to kind of work
with something really cool and foray
into computer vision so and then lastly
we had a team of just cattle enthusiasts
they were data science practitioners but
they've kind of made I want to say a
career but a hobby of working on cattle
competitions and taking learnings from
their prior competitions to feed into
this particular win and so we see that
from across our all our competitions
across all our participants is that
everyone is kind of converging to really
share and learn from one another and
especially in trending areas like
computer vision where advanced
techniques might need to be employees
with me that kind of got mixed up sorry
went backwards so I've kind of covered a
few of the classic use cases for cattle
competitions what I thought I'd talk
about now is kind of where we're headed
so where I'll start with that story is
actually tagless broader vision
so if you've come to tackle lately and
you know you're familiar with our
competitions you'll see that we've
introduced these other product areas
that I've touched on previously kernels
and datasets and so what we envision to
be is a home for data science a place
where people are not just you know
playing but actually doing their data
science project doing their work and we
see that happening by offering a
combination of a rich community that's
ready to share and learn datasets where
you can do your work and then an
environment where people can create code
reproducible code and collaborate on
that code so we see competitions moving
in this direction as well to leverage
these strengths that we are building in
kind of a more genuine way and so what
we're going is towards this concept of
code competitions and so today the way I
described the way competitions are set
up today people are actually submitting
predictions on their that their model is
generating models that they're building
probably locally maybe in some cloud
environments but what we envision is
that people can actually submit their
code and so we've run a handful of these
so far and we're building towards
offering more of these but an example of
this is a competition that we ran hosted
by mercury and so they are in online
marketplace where people sell their
secondhand goods and so they were
looking to improve the prediction of
prices that were suggested to the
sellers of those goods so what they do
is they submit their code within our
tableau colonels environments they can
collaborate with teammates by sharing
that code with those teammates privately
and then they submit the actual code
rather than just the predictions for
that code
what you can imagine is that for the
customers in the equation they're
receiving you know the the code that
that was used to generate the this
emissions in a more reproducible
environment they can also run the that
code on a truly held-out test set and
then for our community they're able to
work in an environment that alight
enables them to truly collaborate with
one another and so this is all kind of
moving towards our goal of really being
a place where people can share and learn
from one another by creating an
environment for them to do so and so
that kind of is our vision for where
we're headed in competitions so I what
I'd like to do now is actually kind of
step you through a live example of a
competition and so I'll start my demo
portion so this is our competitions
listing page any user you sign up for an
account you can get access to this what
I thought I'd do is just kind of show
you so this is just today right the
active competitions we have going on we
have a series of featured competitions
and these are the ones that are
typically hosted by commercial
organizations or companies who are
looking to receive the solutions for
each of the challenges they post you
know how what their prize pool is as
well as you know the the summary of what
they're trying to solve below those we
have a series of getting started
competitions so your classic amnesty and
titanic competitions we refresh these so
people can continue to work on those and
learn especially if you're getting
started and then followed by a series of
research and playground competitions so
you can see that a series of these
playground competitions are are using
our new format
of code competitions so what I thought
I'd do is actually jump into this isn't
necessarily a feature competition but
it's a competition we launched about a
week ago and it was it's being hosted by
the inter-american Development Bank and
they are trying to improve the
prediction of poverty levels within a
country so forth in this case it's Costa
Rica and they're doing this because they
use that as a way to assign Social
Welfare need and and these types of
programs when it loads okay so this is
the live competition site it gives a
little background of what that host is
trying to achieve it gives an overview
of the evaluation metric we're using to
score the submissions and so we have
kind of a library of these evaluation
metrics and we work with the hosts that
identify what they're trying to
emphasize what they're trying to
de-emphasize in order to come to an
evaluation metric that makes the most
sense for that problem we have prizes in
this case it's just cattle swag we're
not this is considered sort of a for a
good challenge and therefore we're not
looking to award prize money and then in
timeline associated and any important
dates the data itself is accessible
through the competitions data page and
we've added some new features the data
of course can only be downloaded after
you've accepted the the competitions
rules and and we have added a new
feature down here around we call data
Explorer and it gives people kind of a
glimpse at what the data for a given
data set looks like so you can download
that that data once you have accepted
the rules for the competition and then
you can use it to train or test
your algorithms performance locally or
in a cloud environment as I mentioned
before there are kernels for the
competition so this these are completely
organically generated by our community
oftentimes they range from exploratory
data analyses so people looking at the
you know the data and and what features
appear to have some importance and
they'll share their notebooks that that
do that type of exploration and plots
and then within kernels also of course
some often basic baseline models as well
our discussion pages is where people
share you know and it so it's about the
approaches that they're taking the types
of features that they're trying to
explore if they want to team up on a
competition and that sort of thing and
then the leaderboard is of course the
ongoing tally of how people are
performing competitions typically lasts
you know two to three months and at the
end of the competition those in the in
the winning spots will receive the the
prizes the other thing that I thought
I'd share in this context is a an actual
kernel model so I'll do that actually
through another competition that I can
highlight we just actually launched
yesterday because I know that we have a
starter kernel that we've created so for
this particular competition it's using
actually a public bigquery data set New
York City Taxi data which includes kind
of the origination point as well as the
end point for a bunch of different taxi
fares and then the corresponding fare
for that ride and so the idea is the pit
to to create models that will predict
what the fare will be based on that data
and so we just launched this this
morning or last night and so
we're still kind of gaining some teams
here but we did create a kernel that
that uses kind of a simple linear model
and so you can kind of see what one of
these looks like that actually generates
a solution what he's done is he's done a
very basic look at the kind of distance
between the two points I mean the start
and end points and then taking a look at
using that as a way to generate a model
for how to predict the fare and this
type of a very basic approach I think
gets him in our MSE value of so that's
root mean squared error which is the
evaluation metric used in this case so
it'll get that our MSE value of maybe
around five or six dollars but what the
competition is hoping to help people do
is make advancements using other
techniques and actually this was hosted
in coordination with Coursera who is
offering a course that's kind of helping
people use penser flow to work on this
type of a problem and so what this does
is it generates an output submission
that can be used to be submitted
directly to a competition for sake of
quickness I've gone ahead and forked
that same kernel and and rerun it commit
it in order to be able to show sort of
how you might take the output of the the
kernel and then submit it to a
competition for evaluation and then what
that does is that immediately generates
your score and then places you on on the
leaderboard for for that competition
so that's kind of the summary of how a
competition works what we're doing you
know different types of use cases that
we're solving for customers okay
well thank you all very much have a
great day
[Music]